اسرار مثابره ومغامره اسمي نوف الجهمي
واكاديميه انا عالمه البيانات في الثقافه
والعلوم الاجتماعيه
ومختصر في الاتصال الاستراتيجي
كان عملي تقريبا 18 حوالي سنه 2010 وكنت
من ضمن برنامج يخص تمكين الشباب في رياده
الاعمال في مدينه مانشستر
فداك اليوم بالتحديد وهذا بعد ما اشتغلنا
على مشاريعنا وشكلنا الفرق والاعضاء وصلنا
لليوم العرض على المستثمرين ابد ما كان في
جلسه تدريبيه في ذلك الوقت
اتذكر كنت في القاعه الاغلبيه فيها شباب
والبنات كانوا قله واللجنه المستثمرين
كلهم كانوا رجال اعمال فوق الاربعين سنه
وهل قاعه كنت اصغر وحده
كميه الخوف اللي كان فيني كان شنيع فداك
الوقت مع هالشعور الشخص يعني طبعا يبغى
يتراجع بعد عده محاولات من منسقه البرنامج
في اني اكمل وصل دورنا ان نقدم واللحظه
مره كنا كانت ثانيتين النتيجه مو مهمه كثر
ما في نفس الليله كنت افكر ودركت انه ولا
شيء يمنعني من تحديد شو من نوع وشكل
النجاح اللي ابغيه مو بنجاح كانتيجه اللي
يمنعك مهما كانت ظروفك ونفسك والخوف
واختيارك للبيئه اللي انت فيها
وهي القناعه اخر شيء انا نحن اللي نحدد
قيمه الافكار
وانا اخذ هالشيك منهج
والحمد لله انطلقت في التجارب عديده
ووصلتني مرحله العطاء والمبادره من ضمنها
نعم مؤسسه عبد الله الغرير من خلال المجلس
الشبابي ومجلس الاهداف التنميه المستدامه
[موسيقى]
التحديات اللي نحن نواجهك يا شباب ان
اغلبيه في الفورمس للشباب تستهدفنا لكن
بدون تواجد نقطه التواصل بين الاجيال
ويكون فعاله بشراكم
[موسيقى]